Bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Nehmen Sie Platz, bitte.
Danke schön.
Am Anfang möchte ich mich kurz vorstellen.
Mein Name ist Temar Göksow.
Ich bin Assistent-Ärzte in dieser Praxis.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen aufnahmegeschiff präferieren.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben,
bitte nehmen Sie eine Seichen geben.
Und dann machen wir ja eine kurze Pause.
Ansonsten so weiter machen.
Sind Sie Einfachsteinen?
Gerne.
Okay.
Am Anfang möchte ich Ihre Personaldaten sprechen.
Und dann sofort möchte ich Ihren aktuelle Beschwerden kommen.
Können Sie sagen, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Hase.
Hase?
Paul Hase.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname bestabeln?
Ich bin ein Meter 70 groß.
Ich wiege 75 kg.
Okay.
Ja, ich bin 75.
7. Juni 1970. Ich bin 53 Jahre alt.
Okay. 53.
Okay. So, was hört es uns?
Also, mir geht es seit ungefähr zwei Wochen immer schlechter.
Ich bekomme weniger Luft, wenn ich mich anstrenge, wenn ich treppen steige,
wenn ich spazieren gehe, wenn ich Fahrrad fahre.
Das macht mir Sorgen.
Mhm.
Tritt das Beschwerden auf bei Belastung? Ja?
Ja, immer nur dann.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Husten?
Selten.
Selten. Okay.
Haben Sie andere Begleitungszentrum mit Atemnot?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Zum Beispiel...
Auswurf, Herzrasen.
Also, Auswurf habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Herzrasen habe ich dann, wenn ich mich anstehe.
Ja, das stimmt.
Okay.
Das hatte ich früher nicht.
Mhm. Okay.
Wann tritt die Atemnot auf?
Beim Einatmen oder Ausatmen?
Einatmen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Haben Sie Köppertemperatur gemessen, oder?
Nein, ich fühle mich nicht krank.
Okay.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht krank.
Mhm. Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass diese Beinen geschwollen?
Ein wenig, ja, habe ich gemerkt. Ein wenig.
Nicht viel, aber die Fußknöchel sind etwas geschwollen.
Fuß.
Aber morgens, wenn ich aufstehe, ist alles okay.
Nachz...
...itz...
Wenn ich morgens, wenn ich aufstehe, ist alles okay.
Aber tagsüber, dann werden die etwas dicker.
Beide Seite oder eine...
eine Seite?
Beide Seiten.
Beide Seite.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay. Okay.
Ähm...
So...
Haben Sie Schützefrust?
Okay, fühle mich nicht krank.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen, keine Probleme beim Stuhlgang.
Gut.
Herr Haase, ähm...
Sie haben keine Fieber, keine Appetitlosigkeit,
keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen und Stuhlgang.
Und ist Ihnen übel oder einmal erbrochen?
Nein.
Okay.
Äh, in Ordnung.
Äh, ich würde gerne mit Ihnen, äh, Ihre vorherige, ähm, Geschichte,
gesprochen, besprochen.
Ähm,
haben Sie eine äh, chronische Erkrankung?
Also, es ist auch Bluthochdruck.
Ich nehme Medikamente dafür ein.
Okay.
Wie, wie ist Ihre äh, ähm, Medikamentnahme?
Ramipril.
Äh, wie viel Milligramm ist das?
Fünf, fünf Milligramm.
Nehmen Sie äh, am Morgen oder?
Morgens, einem morgens.
Einmorgens, okay.
Haben Sie andere ähm, chronische Erkrankungen wie Suckerkrankheit?
Erhöchte Blutverwärte?
Nein, ich habe Kopfschmerzen.
Ich glaube, ich habe Migräne manchmal.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Äh,
eine, eine Arzt sagte sie, sie haben Migräne, sie, sie glaubt.
Ich habe in der letzten Zeit sie aus Kopfschmerzen
und ich glaube, ich habe eine Migräne.
Okay.
Ähm, beim Kopfschmerzen, haben Sie Ihre Bluthochdruck gemessen?
Nein, mein Gerit ist leider kaputt.
Ich konnte nicht messen.
Okay.
Ähm, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Äh, nein.
Nur meine Mandeln sind als Kind rausgenommen worden.
Das ist komplikationlos, oder?
Joja, das ist, da war ich noch ein Kind.
Da war ich noch zehn Jahre alt.
Ich erinnere mich gar nicht mehr so dran.
Mhm.
Okay.
Gibt es irgendwelche, äh, irgendwelche Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nicht bekannt, also eigentlich nicht.
Laktose, Intoleranz oder Polenallergie?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Mhm, okay.
Äh, okay.
Waren Sie im letzten Jahr im Ausland?
Ja, ich war in Afrika.
Afrika.
Wann war das?
Das war jetzt, äh, über Ostern gewesen, vor ungefähr zwei Monaten.
Zwei Monate.
Vor zwei Monaten, ja.
Ungefähr so zwei bis drei Monaten war.
Das war Mitte April gewesen.
Mhm, okay.
Sind Sie gern regelmäßig, äh, Impfung?
Ob ich geimpft wurde?
Wie bitte?
Ob ich geimpft bin?
Ja.
Äh, also zuletzt hat das mein Haushalt kontrolliert?
Okay.
Äh, sind Sie gegen Covid-19 geimpft?
Ja, bin ich. Viermal.
Viermal, okay.
Äh, rachen Sie?
Manchmal, also am Wochenende vielleicht eine oder zwei Zeit.
Manchmal, wenn Freunde da sind.
Mhm, okay.
Ähm, schinken Sie Alkohol?
Auch selten, am Wochenende.
Vielleicht ein bisschen, nicht viel.
Okay.
Ähm, wie meinen Sie nicht viel?
Wie?
Ein Bier oder ein Glas Wein, oder wenn wir mal draußen sind,
vielleicht mal ein Cocktail, so was in Art.
Mhm.
Äh, wie oft das?
Am Wochenende.
Nein, am Wochenende.
Okay.
Ähm, und nehmen Sie das,
bitte nicht persönlich,
das muss ich fragen, das Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich hätte es aktuell oder früher?
Aktuell, als aktuell?
Also jetzt ist es aktuell nämlich keine Drogen rein, nein.
Mhm, damals?
Ja, in meiner Jugend, haben wir schon mal was gemacht, ne?
Mhm.
Ich habe auch schon lange her.
Und ich habe 19 Jahre alt war,
aber das ist schon lange her.
Aktuell nämlich keine Drogen rein.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Äh, so, wie, sind Sie verheiratet, oder?
Ich bin geschieden.
Geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ich?
Ist Sie gesund?
Ja, ist gesund.
Keine, keine Krankenhäuser?
Nein.
Gesund, okay.
Äh, haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe einen Bruder, ja.
Äh, ist er gesund?
Gut.
Ich denke, ja, wir haben nicht so viel Kontakt, aber ich glaube, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Haustiere?
Ich habe eine Katze.
Sie ist auch gesund.
Okay, gut, super.
Äh, so, wo wohnen Sie in einem Wohnung, oder?
Ich wohne in einer Wohnung.
Wohnung.
Ähm, leben Sie alleine oder?
Mit wem leben Sie?
Mit meiner Katze.
Okay.
Sind Sie mit Ihrer Arbeit zufrieden?
Ja, aber ich gehe gerne arbeiten.
Ich kann auch von Hause arbeiten, aber ich gehe gerne arbeiten.
Okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Architekt.
Okay.
Äh, so, gibt es Ihren Nähenverwandtschafts,
eine wichtige Erkrankung, Ihre Vater, Ihre Mutter.
Was heißt das?
Ihr Vater ist gesund, leben Sie Ihre Eltern?
Mein Vater ist verstorben, meine Mutter lebt noch.
Es tut mir leid.
Äh, wissen Sie, dass Ihr Vater wegen was...
Woran mein Vater verstorben ist?
Ja, ja.
Woran?
Ja.
Der ist, der hatte Krebs.
Der hatte Krebs.
Können Sie wieder sagen, Mutter, Ihre Mutter?
Ihre Mutter ist noch, sie ist in einem Seniorenheim.
Sie ist demänzekrankt und hat Zuckererkrankung.
Und sie hat Regamente dafür ein.
Okay.
So, ich habe meine Ausnahmegespräch fertig.
Haben Sie andere, haben Sie Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage, was habe ich denn jetzt?
Was glauben Sie, was ich habe?
Also, ich bin schon besorgt.
Mein Kollege, der ist vor kurzem eine Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Und der alter Mann, der auch diese Beschwerden gehabt.
Ist mir leid.
Können Sie eine Herzerkrankung haben?
Ähm, zurzeit?
Oder ist das die Junge vielleicht?
Zurzeit haben wir nur eine Amnesiegespräch führen.
So, das ist so früh eine Diagnose sagen.
Und ich möchte eine Untersuchung, körperliche Untersuchung machen
und dann eine andere Untersuchung, zum Beispiel Laborte,
machen und dann ich sage richtige Diagnose ihnen.
Und ich möchte ihnen ein bisschen geduld sein
und dann ich erkläre sie, was haben sie
und was machen wir für ihre Gesundheit, ihre Beschwerden.
Und dann ich möchte mit meiner Chef über ihre Beschwerden sprechen
und dann ich gebe sie Bescheid, was machen wir über ihre Beschwerden.
Also soll ich Sie warten?
Ja, bitte, in Wartezimmer ein bisschen warten
und dann ich spreche mit meiner Chef.
Danke.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen eine Frage?
Ja.
Halb, halb, haben Sie Probleme einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Äh, in den letzten zwei Wochen habe ich Durchschlafprobleme.
Ich muss aufstehen und Wasser lassen.
Aber ansonsten habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme.
Ja, wie oft müssen Sie nachts Wasser lassen?
Also zweimal ungefähr.
Seit wann?
Seit zwei Wochen.
Okay.
Wie viele Küsten nutzen Sie beim Schlafen?
Noch eins.
Okay.
Essen Sie gerne strategisches und oder fettiges Essen?
Gemischt.
Immer so und so.
Okay.
Haben Sie so seit umgehört ab oder so genommen?
Ich habe 2 kg genommen.
Okay.
Danke.
Das war meine Frage.
Was ich noch, egal, machen wir gleich.
Sie sind seit einer steckenden Krankheit?
Nein.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass ich schwindelig oder nachschweiß?
Schwindelig ist mir, wenn ich mich belasten kann.
Wenn ich mal treppenstelle hoch gehe oder beim Einkaufen was hoch tragen muss,
dann ist mir auch ein bisschen schwindelig.
Nachschweiß ist mir nicht mehr.
Wie viele Stufen können Sie steigen, bevor Sie?
Wie viele Stufen können Sie steigen,
bevor Sie?
Also ich habe mit einer Etage kein Problem, aber ab der zweiten Etage merke ich schon,
dass ich mehr atmen muss.
Sie sind so etwas freier schon einmal?
Nein.
Deswegen bin ich so besorgt und habe Angst.
Sie sind deswegen schon bei einem anderen als gewesen?
Nein, mein Haushalt ist im Urlaub.
Ich liebe hier, haben Sie langsam oder plötzlich angefangen?
Ja, plötzlich zunehmend. Das wird jetzt immer mehr.
Seit zwei Wochen wird es von Tag zu Tag mehr.
Entschuldigung, ich habe auch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Ihre Beine Rötchenfarbe gemerkt?
Nein, die sind nicht gerötet, aber am Tag über werden die immer dicker,
sie sind schwoller.
Okay, haben Sie diese Beine Rötchenfarbe,
das seid Ihre Reise?
Nein, jetzt auch kurz mehr.
Vielen Dank.
Ich denke alle Fragen, die ich da hatte, können wir als erstes
eine Anpangen zu machen?
Ja.
Bitte schön, Simon.
Guten Tag, Herr Chef.
Heute habe ich eine neue Patient.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen über meine Patientinbeschwerden
sprechen und vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Gerne, bitte schön.
Okay.
Paul Hase ist 170 cm.
1,70 m.
25 kg.
75 kg.
보stmitteln erfolgreiches southwest tteokbokki
1,70 m.
1,75 m.
1,50 m.
1,25 m.
Ja, 51 Jahre alt.
53 Jahre alt, ja.
Was ist?
Okay, 1970.
Okay.
Er ist 53 Jahre alt.
Er eroistet seit zwei Wochen,
bei Belastung
plötzlich
Atmung gehabt.
Ja, als er sich für die Muslime
ja, der Teilnis.
Ja, düsbne, düsbne gehabt.
Hat er
selten
Gusten,
während dieser düsbne
Er hat
er hat
ein, plötzlich ein
Atmische düsbne.
Er hat auch
Bein geschwollen.
Beide Seite.
Er hat keine Wulschmerzen,
keine Fieber.
Diese
und diese Geschwellung, keine Rötung.
Er hat auch
das, das Schwellung
tritt tagsüber auf.
Die Schwellung.
Die Schwellung, die Schwellung
tritt tagsüber auf.
Seit zwei Wochen
hat er
zweimal am Nacht
beim Waslassen.
Geht zweimal in der Nacht
steht er auf zum Waslassen.
Geht er auf zum Waslassen?
Man kann fragen,
Nikduril.
Während dieser Zeit
hat er zwei Kilogramm zugenommen.
Wenn beim Treppensteigen
hat er
schwindelig.
Ist nicht schwindelig.
Er hat kein
Öbelkeit,
keine Fieber, keine
Appetitlosigkeit.
Am Anfang der Erkrankungen
hat er leider
Atelierhypertonie.
Seit wann?
Ich vergesse.
Am Morgen, einmal am Tag,
er nimmt
er am April 5 Milligramm ein.
Seit wann?
Seit zwei Wochen,
seit drei Monaten, seit zehn Jahren.
Die Frage muss man stellen.
Seit wann nimmt er den Medikament ein?
Ja, ich vergesse.
Als Kind
hat er
Tonzilik-Thema operiert.
Vor zwei Monaten
hat er nach
Afrika gereist.
Wo in Afrika?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Südafrika, Nordafrika,
Centralafrika.
Ich muss fragen.
Hat er
keine
nichts allergisch?
Er hat 4 mal Covid-19
Impfung geimpft.
Er hat 4 Mal Covid-19
geimpft.
Er rauchte
am Wochenende mit Freunden
ein oder zwei
Zigaretten.
Auch am Wochenende
trinkt er
Alkohol,
ein oder zwei Glas.
Er hat
keine
Drogenkontakte.
Er ist geschieden.
Er hat ein Tochter.
Sie ist gesund.
Er ist auch gesund.
Er hat ein Bruder.
Er ist
sein Vater
wegen
Prostatkrebs gestorben.
Und seine Mutter
lebt
heim.
Und
seine Mutter
hat
eine Bluterkrankung.
Welche Bruder?
Was hat er gesagt?
Er hat gesagt.
Er hat gesagt,
er screensite.
Er hat gesagt, er screenete.
Er hat ein Katze und erlebt mit seiner Katze im Monum Mutter Demenz und Diabetes.
Ich habe die Fragen gestellt. Hat er erzählt, dass er Rhythmusstörungen hat?
Hat er bemerkt, dass er Rhythmusstörungen hat?
Er hat gesagt, dass er Rhythmusstörungen hat?
Hat er bemerkt, dass er das Herz stolp hat?
Nein, nein ich.
Wichtige Frage, die Sie stellen musst.
Das könnte Vorflimmern sein.
Das kann es noch sein.
Vielleicht können die anderen mithelfen auch.
Also pulmulale Mully glaube ich nicht.
Ja, das ist plötzlich nicht zwei Wochen her.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Bitte.
Keine Brustschmerzen.
Keine Brustschmerzen, hast du an der gesagt, ne?
Ja.
Keine Anginapektors.
Es könnte vieles sein.
Man muss die Differenzialdiagnosen aufstellen.
Wir haben ein Patient, der hat eine Belastungsdüstepne.
Er hat wahrscheinlich eine Tachikadie.
Wir wissen aber nicht, welchen Rhythmus er hat,
weil wir nicht gefragt haben.
Er hat einen bekannten Bluthochdruck.
Wir wissen nicht seit wann.
Er hat nicht gemessen.
Vor kurzem.
Er hat, das kann viele Differenzialdiagnose jetzt sein.
Die müssen wir ausschließen.
Wir können mal aufzählen.
Also Herzinsuffizienz.
Rechts oder links.
Welche ist das?
Links oder rechts?
Neu, links.
Rechts vielleicht eher, ne?
Legen unterschiedliche Ideen zum Beispiel.
Links, Herzinsuffizienz.
Er vermerrt Luftnot, Lumenideen,
Pleureigöste zum Beispiel.
Dann kann es auch ein Vorruflemern sein.
Richtig?
Ja.
Was in einer Herzinsuffizienz resultiert.
Es kann aber auch ein klappende Vizium sein.
Eine Herzklappenprobleme.
Aber hat eine klappende Stinneose zum Beispiel.
Wissen wir nicht.
Es kann aber auch eine Schmerzfläche sein.
Ein Beispiel, wissen wir nicht.
Es kann aber auch eine Myocarditis sein.
Vielleicht hat eine Myocarditis,
die jetzt langsam zum Vorstand tritt.
Wissen wir nicht.
Es kann viele, viele Differenzialdiagnose sein.
Lungenentzündung glaube ich nicht.
Es kann auch keine fieberen Lungenartiere in den Bulli sein.
Aber die würde dann nicht so sein.
Es müsste eine chronische Embulie sein.
Aber hier liegt der Verdacht nach,
dass es eventuell eine Herzinsuffizienz sein könnte.
Aber warum, wissen wir nicht.
Es kann auch einfach eine hypertensive Geschichte sein.
Vielleicht ist der Patient immer hypertensiv.
Hat er über Kopfschmerzen geklagt?
Ja.
Kann sein.
Vielleicht hat er immer erhöhten Blutdruck.
Das könnte jetzt eine hypertensive Herzerkrankung sein.
Wissen wir dann noch näher.
Im Blut und im Ultraschall in EKG kann man das sehen.
Oder im Belastungs-EKG kann man das sehen.
Was würden Sie denn an Labor abnehmen bei den Patienten?
Kann man das im Blut sehen?
Ob er eine Herzinsuffizienz hat?
Ente probenpe kann man messen.
Ich würde auch troponin messen.
Troponin kann auch bei hypertensiver Erkrankung hoch sein.
Das kann aber auch bei einer Anierenden-Suffizienz sein.
Aber das haben wir nicht gefragt.
Weil die letzte Blutabnahme war, haben wir alles nicht gefragt.
Aber er hat keine relevante Vorerkrankung.
Was würde man sehen, wenn er eine rechtsherzinsuffizienz hat?
Kann man das im EKG sehen?
Ich glaube ja.
Kann man eine Herzinsuffizienz am EKG sehen?
Vielleicht ja.
Was sagen die anderen?
Kann man das sehen?
Es gibt Kardiologen unter uns.
Kann man eine Herzinsuffizienz am EKG sehen?
Ja.
Wie kann man das sehen?
Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Wie kann man die Herzinsuffizienz haben?
haben könnte oder ist es falsch zeigt das nicht die hypertrophie kann man das nicht als okay dann
habe ich das falsch gesagt ich dachte man kann das sehen das kann man in dem Röntgen sehen kann
wenn wenn das ist links link hat sie hat in sie sie hat man
in ergus in lungen im Beispiel richtig und wo kann man das am besten sehen ob man eine
Herzinfektions hat welche Untersuchung
und es schokalografie
im essho kann man es gut sehen
hier wäre wichtig gewesen zu fragen ob der Patient Herzstolpern bemerkt hat
bei ihrer Anamnese vielleicht ein Vorruf lemon haben könnte da muss man gezielt drauf fragen
manchmal sagen die Patienten das nicht die sagen dann ja ich habe Herzrasen wenn die das sagen
da müssten sie fragen oder sollten sie fragen ob er auch eine Rhythmusstörung bemerkt hat
haben sie Herzstolpern bemerkt haben sie Rhythmusstörungen bemerkt ja manchmal merken die das manchmal
nicht aber die frage sollte man trotzdem stellen ja genau die frage
natürlich zu jedem körperlichen ersuchung des herzlichen immer die untersuchung des blutdrucks mit
definitiv vital parameter müssten sie in der notaufnahme oder in der praxis wenn sie in der
praxisarbeit auf jeden fall kontrollieren blutdruck herzfrequenz und wenn sie haben sauerstoffsättigung
und natürlich die körperliche untersuchung nun abhören herz abhören herzklappen abhören
ist ganz wichtig blutdruck essenziell müssten sie machen wenn sie das nicht machen dann haben
sie einen großen fehler begangen weil der patient erzählt ja er hat eine blutdruck erkrankung
sein blutdruck wurde seit mehreren wochen nicht gemessen als ein gerät kaputt ist und sie haben
belastungsküsse bei den patienten und eine tachikadi also belastungstachikadi unterschemkel
das kann alles auch auf eine hypotensiverkankung zuzuführen sein oder
auch das ist richtig aber ich habe gesagt zwei wochen nicht mehr zum urlaub
gegen hypertension pertinent genau kann man fragen ist das in kontrolle aber wir haben
gar nicht gefragt ihr seid wann nimmt ihr das medikament seit gestern zwei wochen drei wochen
drei jahre das ist eine wichtige frage gestellt müssen ich habe den anfangen der eine befolgt
geschrieben das ist richtig ich er hat sich bei uns wegen seit zwei wochen bestehender progredienter
belastung abhängig der diesmal vorgegter er berichtete das diesmal vor zwei wochen akut
ohne auslöse aufgetreten zahir fernes zahir der patiatin folgende begleicht sind
auf gefallen takikade perferal ödeme niktüren es liegt keine folgende symptom
angene pektoris fiba ausfurcht ortobne nachschweiß
das ist richtig
noch andere fragen
hat die mand
Kann ich ein bisschen zuhören?
Ja, ein bisschen zuhören.